Hey, Vsauce. It's Michael with two big
announcements.
Count them two. First of all, there's a brand new
episode of Vsauce Leanback
that you can start by clicking the link
at the top of this video's description.
This week the topic is crazy and classic
social psychology experiments.
Three years ago I was at the University
of Chicago studying psychology.
I mainly did neuropsychology, but it was the social stuff,
the social experiments, that really were fun to watch.
So I went head and went through YouTube and put
together some of my favorite taped
experiments.
A lot of these are actually very very
classic and have been very important to
understanding how we act
around other people.
Speaking of other people,
we have a brand new "Sauciest of the Week."
Remember that Sauciest of the Week is
given to a member of the community,
a fellow WeSaucer who's done something cool,
whether it's just a simple awesome
comment, a great recommendation for a
website or a game
or if they made something or made a video that we think we should all see. Now,
each week the winner is determined by
last week's winner
and last week the first one was chosen
by myself - I picked sofusser.
Well sofusser got back to me and said that this
week's winner should be roadhousee.
Why? Because of this video he has about goats
climbing up a steep wall.
Saucy!
Roadhousee, if you're out there, get
back to me about who you think from the
WeSauce community should win next week
for doing something awesome or having
something cool you think we should see.
But seriously, what are you waiting for?
Click the link at the top of this video's
description to start lean back.
If you're on a phone, as you know,
it won't really work yet,
so wait until it's a better time or if you're really impatient,
I did put links to everything I cover in
this video's description.
So, have fun...
And as always,
thanks for watching.